Hello, I'm Sean Hayes. I'm an actor. Special skills include being able to bounce a tennis ball on a racket 153 consecutive times. Another special skill is picking my nose without people watching or people knowing. Shit. Welcome to SmartLess. Sean, I don't think I've ever seen you grumpy, ever. Oh, yeah. Well, I'll live with me for a couple of days. Oh, challenge much. But what gets you grumpy? I mean, I guess only, I guess Scotty would be the answer to that. That's what gets you grumpy. That's why I haven't seen it, huh?
你好，我是肖恩·海耶斯。我是一名演员。我的特长包括能连续153次用球拍颠网球。另一个特长是可以在别人没看见或不知道的情况下抠鼻子。该死。欢迎来到《SmartLess》。肖恩，我觉得我从来没见过你脾气暴躁的样子，一次都没有。哦，是吗。好吧，跟我住上几天你就知道了。哦，这是在挑战吗。但什么会让你脾气暴躁呢？我的意思是，我想，我想答案应该是斯科蒂。那就是让你脾气暴躁的原因。这就是为什么我没见过，对吧？
Sometimes Scotty makes you grumpy. Well, look, when you live with somebody, right, doesn't Amanda make you grumpy? Everybody, every spouse makes him grumpy. Yeah. Why would you ask that question? And you make her grumpy and we all make each other grumpy. It is, you know, actually Amanda and I had a nice talk about that. Oh, recently? Yeah. Basically like, well, this is, it's a choice.
有时候斯科蒂会让你脾气暴躁。好吧，听着，当你和某人住在一起时，对吧，阿曼达不会让你脾气暴躁吗？每个人，每个配偶都会让他脾气暴躁。是的。你为什么要问那个问题？你也会让她脾气暴躁，我们都会让彼此脾气暴躁。你知道，其实阿曼达和我对此进行过一次很好的谈话。哦，最近吗？是的。基本上就是，嗯，这是一种选择。
It's a real choice. Like, it's pretty easy to stay grumpy, make your partner grumpy and just live in grumpiness. It's, it's, it's, it's life-lifting. Yeah. Yeah. But, uh, it's such a small. Well, I always say you have to fall in respect with somebody, not in love with them, because if you don't have respect, you don't have love. Yeah, you can say that.
这确实是一种选择。就像，保持暴躁、让你的伴侣也暴躁并生活在暴躁中其实很容易。这，这，这，这很消耗生命。是的。是的。但是，呃，这太小了。嗯，我总是说你必须和某人产生尊重，而不是坠入爱河，因为如果你没有尊重，你就没有爱。是的，你可以这么说。
Have you ever thought about making it on t-shirts or something? Like. Or even a bumper sticker. Yeah, you got everything like a center, like up in New York. No, you know what? You know what? You know our friend Josh Shotland said to me the other day, Willie, um, he passed on a, a sage saying, um, you'll never treat anyone better than you treat yourself. Oh, there you go.
你有没有想过把它印在T恤上之类的？比如。或者甚至是一个保险杠贴纸。是的，你拥有像纽约中心那样的所有东西。不，你知道吗？你知道吗？你知道我们的朋友乔什·肖特兰前几天对我说了什么吗，威利，嗯，他传达了一句至理名言，嗯，你永远不会比对待自己更好地对待别人。哦，就是这样。
So, you know. Well, here's what, here's something Scottie and I argued about yesterday. We, he was talking about having a meeting with this person for a potential gig, because he's a composer. He writes music. And so I was like, I jumped all over him about, this is what you got to do. You got to talk to him like this. You got to bring it. And when you bring your stuff, make sure you show him this music that you did. And then this music, but it's got to be in this order because it grows. See from this, from the ballot to the more complicated. I'm already mad at you.
所以，你知道。好吧，这是斯科蒂和我昨天争论的事情。我们，他当时在谈论要和这个人开会，讨论一个潜在的工作机会，因为他是一名作曲家。他写音乐。所以我当时就像，我对他大加指责，说这就是你必须做的。你必须这样跟他谈。你必须拿出点东西来。当你展示你的作品时，一定要让他看你做的这些音乐。然后是这些音乐，但必须按这个顺序，因为它是递进的。从这个，从抒情曲到更复杂的。我已经对你生气了。
He looks at me like he's going to fucking kill me. Right. Like, Hey, Hollywood, how about I just take a nice meeting? Just, I've been doing well just by myself. And I was like, okay. And so, uh, and I go, I'm just, I'm just here to help. And he goes, see a loser. Is that what she said to her kicked him in the ass. And then he got. But I say, but I say, I said, I'm only trying to help you. And he was, I know that. But sometimes you don't hear your, the way you hear yourself.
他看着我，好像要杀了我一样。对吧。就像，嘿，好莱坞，我只是去开个好会怎么样？我一个人一直做得很好。我说，好吧。然后，呃，我说，我只是，我只是想帮忙。他说，看，失败者。那是她对他说的吗，踢了他的屁股。然后他得到了。但我说，但我说，我说，我只是想帮你。他说，我知道。但有时候你听不到你，你听自己的方式。
So Sean, that's a great point. I think that for me, one of the things that I noticed that has taken me a long time is tone. And sometimes people misinterpret my tone. And I get very, uh, uh, I get very sort of fired up about stuff or whatever. And they, this is everybody. This is sort of friends, kids, um, partners, whatever. But I live for when you get fired up. I love that. And I just, but I actually don't mean it. And I think that what happens is people misinterpret it anyway. I tend to, I tend to get, uh, uh, uh, insincerely passionate about things too. Um, uh, but
所以肖恩，这是一个很好的观点。我想对我来说，我注意到的一件花了我很长时间的事情是语气。有时人们会误解我的语气。我变得非常，呃，呃，我对事情变得非常激动，或者其他什么。他们，这是每个人。这有点像朋友、孩子、嗯，伴侣，等等。但我活着就是为了当你激动的时候。我喜欢那样。我只是，但我其实不是那个意思。我认为发生的事情是人们无论如何都会误解它。我倾向于，我倾向于变得，呃，呃，呃，对事情也变得不真诚地充满热情。嗯，呃，但是
also my, that heavy brow of mine at 53, uh, we've talked about this. I, I look, I look pretty, pretty pissed off just when listening. Um, your brow is now where your eyes are. Yeah. My bad mood is just gravity. That's all that is. Don't worry. Um, gang, um, I got, um, uh, I got, um, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, I got a real peach for us today. Today's guest, this fella is smart and handsome. He's famous, but private. An academic but disarming. He's got a degree from Yale, his own show, couple kids, 19 Emmys.
还有我的，我那浓重的眉毛，53岁了，呃，我们谈过这个。我，我看起来，我看起来相当，相当生气，即使只是在听的时候。嗯，你的眉毛现在和你的眼睛在同一个位置了。是的。我的坏心情只是重力。这就是全部。别担心。嗯，伙计们，嗯，我得到了，嗯，呃，我得到了，嗯，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，我今天为我们准备了一个真正的宝贝。今天的嘉宾，这家伙聪明又英俊。他很有名，但很低调。一位学者，但让人放下戒心。他拥有耶鲁大学的学位，有自己的节目，有几个孩子，19座艾美奖。
What? Yeah. He's worked in over 40 countries. He's written three books, all of them best sellers, and He's just launched a podcast because we need more. We needed more and that's why we got into it. Yeah. We're gonna have, we're gonna have to ask him what Stimuliti's addicted to to get all this done
什么？是的。他在40多个国家工作过。他写了三本书，全部都是畅销书，而且他刚刚推出了一个播客，因为我们需要更多。我们需要更多，这就是我们参与其中的原因。是的。我们得问问他，他到底对什么上瘾才能完成所有这些工作
and why he's agreed to do our show. I'm a big, big long time fan and super excited to welcome Anderson Cooper. Oh my! Come on in Anderson. Mr. Anderson Cooper. Yeah. How's it going? Wait, 19 Emmys. 19 Emmys. You know they're news Emmys though
以及为什么他同意参加我们的节目。我是安德森·库珀的忠实粉丝，非常高兴欢迎他。哦，天哪！进来吧，安德森。安德森·库珀先生。是的。怎么样？等等，19座艾美奖。19座艾美奖。你知道那是新闻艾美奖吧
so it's not real. Sure. Still gold. Hey, nobody cares. There's not a ceremony. There's no one watching it. Yes, there is. Yes, there is.
所以那不是真的。当然。依然是金色的。嘿，没人关心。没有颁奖典礼。没人看。有的，有的。
I remember visiting you in your office. Yeah, Sean, I think you're the only, in this trio, the only one person I've actually met. But I'm, I'm, I'm intimidated. I'm a huge admirer of everybody here. So I love your podcasts. I've listened. I'm the least successful Cooper ever on your podcast,
我记得去过你的办公室。是的，肖恩，我想你是这三人组中，我唯一真正见过的人。但我，我，我感到很畏惧。我是这里所有人的忠实崇拜者。所以我喜欢你们的播客。我听过。顺便说一句，我是你们播客上最不成功的库珀，
by the way. Where do we book TB? Hey, what, what? I just, your level of accomplishments are just, they're pretty stunning. And I'm just going to go start right on question 11. By the way, am I the only one without a hat? Yeah.
顺便说一句。我们去哪里预订TB？嘿，什么，什么？我只是，你的成就水平简直令人震惊。我打算直接从第11个问题开始。顺便问一下，我是唯一一个没戴帽子的人吗？是的。
Yeah. We told you to get a hat. Will we have access to one or? You had time to get one when I asked you to. I mean, I got this. That'll work. Okay, that's good. Listener, he's just put on a war correspondent helmet.
是的。我们告诉过你要戴帽子。我们能拿到一个吗，或者？我让你拿的时候你有时间拿一个。我的意思是，我有这个。那行得通。好的，那很好。听众们，他刚刚戴上了一顶战地记者的头盔。
This is the first person who's been embedded with SmartLess. I want, I'm going to get to that. But I want- Listen, did you just play golf? I mean, is this- Wait, no, I don't. I don't play golf. I don't play golf.
这是第一个嵌入《SmartLess》的人。我想，我要谈谈这个。但我想要——听着，你刚才去打高尔夫球了吗？我的意思是，这是——等等，不，我没有。我不打高尔夫。我不打高尔夫。
Do you want to see my shorts? You were on like a, last I heard, you were on a like a every day for the last 101 days or something. Yeah. I'm trying to catch up a little bit. Willie's going to jump into the hole with me on Tuesday. I beg your pardon.
你想看我的短裤吗？你当时在，我最后听说，你在过去101天里每天都在打球还是什么的。是的。我正试图赶上一点。威利周二要和我一起跳进洞里。请原谅。
I'm back. Yeah, I'm back Tuesday. No, I'm back Saturday. Is there a better way to say that? I know. There's a much better way. So long. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
我回来了。是的，我周二回来。不，我周六回来。有更好的说法吗？我知道。有更好的说法。再见。等等，等等，等等，等等。
No, here comes my question. What about, all these accomplishments- We're so excited. This is an easy but tough question. What's left? What do you want to do, Anderson? Tell me what the goal is. You just jumped to the end?
不，我的问题来了。那么，所有这些成就——我们太兴奋了。这是一个简单但棘手的问题。还剩下什么？你想做什么，安德森？告诉我目标是什么。你直接跳到最后了？
I know, to be honest with you. I'm working on, at the end of the interview, I'm working on an ice show. Do you have ice? You're going to go ice skating? No, it's going to be like, it's like Anderson on ice kind of thing. Kind of a review of my life, but on ice.
我知道，说实话。我正在做，在采访结束时，我正在做一个冰上表演。你有冰吗？你要去滑冰吗？不，它会像，就像安德森冰上秀之类的东西。算是对我人生的回顾，但在冰上。
Okay. Shaking, not stirring. It's the same costume designer as Shrek on ice. Yeah. You're just going to use all those same costumes. Some plays my mom and my dad. It's a great answer. My dad brother.
好的。摇匀，不要搅拌。它和《怪物史莱克》冰上秀的服装设计师是同一个人。是的。你只是要用所有那些相同的服装。有些人扮演我的妈妈和爸爸。这是一个很棒的答案。我爸爸兄弟。
You know, it's going to be really good. Listen, I have some experience. I have a lot of experience with ice productions. So, you know, just let me know. I played a figure skater. No, but Willie knows his way around an ice rink, you know? He's got a real power dumper on him and he can get after it.
你知道，这会非常棒。听着，我有一些经验。我在冰上制作方面有很多经验。所以，你知道，只要告诉我。我扮演过花样滑冰运动员。不，但威利很了解溜冰场，你知道吗？他有一个真正的强力屁股，他可以去追求它。
What's a power dumper? Power dumper's what skaters get. It's a pro dumper. Oh, you mean like a big butt? Pro dumper. It's a pro dumper. Yeah, it's a shelf. It's called a pro dumper.
什么是强力屁股？强力屁股是滑冰运动员得到的。这是职业屁股。哦，你是说像个大屁股？职业屁股。这是职业屁股。是的，它是一个架子。它被称为职业屁股。
That's what hockey guys have. We had pro dumper. Like muscle ass, like a big muscle ass. Bro, thank you, Sean, for putting into terms like an understand. Yeah, gay muscle ass. So, all right. So you're not going to give me an honest answer
这就是曲棍球运动员有的。我们有职业屁股。就像肌肉屁股，就像一个大肌肉屁股。兄弟，谢谢你，肖恩，用一种能理解的方式表达出来。是的，同性恋肌肉屁股。所以，好吧。所以你不会给我一个诚实的答案
because to do that would be... What was it? Well, you're too humble to give me a real answer about what's left, what is next? What would you... What is there left for you to do? I mean, you know, 360 is enough, but you're also on 60 minutes for God's sake.
因为那样做会是……是什么？好吧，你太谦虚了，不能给我一个关于还剩下什么、接下来是什么的真实答案？你会……你还剩下什么可以做？我的意思是，你知道，360已经足够了，但你也在《60分钟》节目上，看在上帝的份上。
Like you're at the pinnacle of any journalistic goal. I'm Leslie Stahl. I'm Anderson Cooper every Sunday. Like what else would you want? And you've written books. You know, my dad died at 50 and I always expected to die at 50. So I planned my whole life in an accelerated version
就像你处于任何新闻目标的巅峰。我是莱斯利·斯塔尔。我每周日都是安德森·库珀。就像你还想要什么？而且你写过书。你知道，我爸爸50岁去世了，我一直以为我会在50岁去世。所以我计划了我整个人生的加速版本
of I'm going to die at 50. So I need to get everything in by then. Can I be honest with you? None of us thought you were going to make it past 50. We all lost. So when I hit 51, I was like, what the fuck do I do now? I don't have a plan.
我会在50岁去世。所以我需要在那个时候完成所有事情。我能诚实地告诉你吗？我们没人认为你能活过50岁。我们都输了。所以当我到了51岁时，我就想，我现在该死地做什么？我没有计划。
And so I have been asking myself that question for the last couple of years and I have kids now and that is the greatest thing I've ever done. And so that's a whole, that's my future. And I love, I like what I do. I mean, I love, you know, I love telling other people's stories.
所以我过去几年一直在问自己这个问题，我现在有孩子了，这是我做过的最伟大的事情。所以这就是全部，这就是我的未来。而且我喜欢，我喜欢我所做的事情。我的意思是，我喜欢，你知道，我喜欢讲述别人的故事。
So, I mean, I have no actual skills so there's nothing else I can do. Oh, please. You're brilliant, you're brilliant. You've got your degree in political science. You're actually succeeding in something you studied. Plus you had to spend one night a year on TV with Andy Cohen, which is a skill in and of itself.
所以，我的意思是，我没有任何实际技能，所以没有其他事情可做。哦，拜托。你很聪明，你很聪明。你拥有政治学学位。你实际上在你学习的领域取得了成功。另外，你每年还得在电视上和安迪·科恩待上一晚，这本身就是一种技能。
I mean, what a handful that guy is. Jesus Christ. Hey, Will, do you know? I do know Andy. I do know Andy. Yeah, no, no, no, I've known Andy for a long time. I would like to know him. He and I were set up on a blind date like 25 years ago.
我的意思是，那家伙真是个麻烦。天哪。嘿，威尔，你知道吗？我确实认识安迪。我确实认识安迪。是的，不，不，不，我认识安迪很久了。我想认识他。大约25年前，我和他被安排了一次盲目约会。
No way. Were you really? How'd that go? Oh, we never had it because he called, he was a producer at CBS News at the time on the morning show. And people were like, oh, you're gay and you're both in news, so you should meet.
不会吧。真的吗？那次约会怎么样？哦，我们从来没去过，因为他打电话时，他当时是哥伦比亚广播公司新闻部晨间节目的制片人。人们当时说，哦，你是同性恋，你们都在新闻界，所以你们应该见见。
And anyway, he called me up to set up the date and within 30 seconds I knew I was never going on a date with Andy Cohen because he violated like every one of my rules and the biggest one being, he mentioned my mom within the first 30 seconds and he now admits he just wanted to date the Vanderbilt boys. Sure, that was so gauche. Wait a second.
总之，他打电话给我安排约会，在30秒内我就知道我永远不会和安迪·科恩约会，因为他违反了我所有的规则，其中最大的一条是，他在前30秒内提到了我妈妈，他现在承认他只是想和范德比尔特家的男孩约会。当然，那太笨拙了。等一下。
So for my sister, your mom's Glory of Vanderbilt. This is killing me. That is so unbranded for Andy. It's so amazing. How did he bring it up? Oh, he was just like your Glory of Vanderbilt's son. I mean, he's not subtle. Hey, did you guys ever make a pact that like
所以对于我姐姐，你妈妈的格洛丽亚·范德比尔特。这简直要了我的命。这对安迪来说太不符合品牌了。这太神奇了。他是怎么提出来的？哦，他就像你格洛丽亚·范德比尔特的儿子。我的意思是，他不含蓄。嘿，你们有没有达成过什么协议，比如
if he's single by a certain age and you're single by a certain age, sure, let's just get together and mine families? No, it's not possible. We're really close friends. I mean, I love him, but that would not work. I love it. By the way, Sean, you said that
如果他在某个年龄还是单身，而你在某个年龄还是单身，当然，让我们聚在一起，合并家庭？不，那是不可能的。我们是非常亲密的朋友。我的意思是，我爱他，但这行不通。我喜欢它。顺便说一句，肖恩，你说了那个
and Andy is such a great guy. I love him. He's so profoundly funny to me. He makes me, he really cracks me up. Why don't you bring him on the show, aren't that? Well, just because I can't, I don't know. It's just a lot. But no, no, I'm kidding.
安迪真是个好人。我爱他。他对我来说非常深刻地有趣。他让我，他真的让我大笑。你为什么不把他带到节目上，安德森？嗯，只是因为我不能，我不知道。这只是很多。但不，不，我在开玩笑。
I love him. I am gonna have him on the show. But it's funny, Sean, you bring up the thing about, hey, we make a pact. You know what people say of that all the time? Like so-and-so, we made a pact that if we weren't married by, and I always call it like, that's just bullshit. That's like some weird bullshit old thing that people do.
我爱他。我会让他上节目的。但很有趣，肖恩，你提到了那个关于，嘿，我们达成协议的事情。你知道人们总是怎么说那个吗？比如某某，我们达成协议，如果我们到了某个年龄还没结婚，我总是称之为，那简直是胡扯。那就像人们做的某种奇怪的胡扯的旧事。
Has anyone ever done that? No, nobody's ever done it. And they all talk about it in this way that's really stupid and nostalgic. Oh, thank you. And just full of BS. All right, we'll be right back. We take commercials, right?
有人真的做过吗？不，从来没有人做过。他们都以一种非常愚蠢和怀旧的方式谈论它。哦，谢谢。而且充满了废话。好吧，我们马上回来。我们做广告，对吧？
We do commercials on this show. We don't, not anymore. I like the commercials you guys do. So was that some of that, that was some of that passion, often misinterpreted for hostility? Yeah, yeah, by the way, I don't really care about it. All right, somebody asked him a question. I gotta go to my question list.
我们在这个节目上做广告。我们不，不再做了。我喜欢你们做的广告。所以那是那种，那是那种经常被误解为敌意的热情吗？是的，是的，顺便说一句，我真的不在乎。好吧，有人问他一个问题。我得去看看我的问题清单。
Oh yeah, no, I wanna know. So when you go, when I walked into your office, I don't know, this is like three years ago. I flew to, I flew from LA to New York to CNN to do three commercials in one day and then flew home. And I stopped and I was like running on fumes. I ran into your office and I think I made a fool out of myself.
哦，是的，不，我想知道。所以当你去，当我走进你的办公室时，我不知道，这大概是三年前的事了。我从洛杉矶飞到纽约去CNN一天拍了三个广告，然后飞回家。我停下来，我当时就像在耗尽精力。我跑进你的办公室，我想我让自己出丑了。
I was like, Anderson, what's going on? Got into any, you have any, I'm Emmys done in the back and she's got like 19 Emmys in the back. Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And I made like joke, joke, joke. And then I left and you're probably like, How did you describe that encounter, Anderson,
我当时就像，安德森，怎么了？有没有，你有没有，我在后面看到艾美奖，她后面有19座艾美奖。等等，等等，等等，等等。我开了个玩笑，玩笑，玩笑。然后我离开了，你可能就像，安德森，你是怎么描述那次相遇的，
to other people? It was like the greatest thing that had happened to me for like the month. That was the first time we met. Come on. And then I did a little interview with you for the doctor you were working on. Yeah, that's right.
对其他人？那就像那个月发生在我身上最棒的事情。那是我们第一次见面。拜托。然后我为你正在做的纪录片做了一个小采访。是的，没错。
Thank you for that. Anderson, tell me how journalism got started with you. Why did you get excited about it and at what age? I, you know, I watched a lot of news as a kid growing up. I was a total nerd and I was interested in how stories are told. My dad was a writer and my mom wrote. And so, yeah, we, we didn't-
谢谢你。安德森，告诉我新闻业是怎么开始的。你为什么对它感到兴奋，在什么年龄？我，你知道，我小时候看了很多新闻。我是一个彻头彻尾的书呆子，我对故事是如何讲述的很感兴趣。我爸爸是作家，我妈妈也写。所以，是的，我们，我们没有——
Who's your mom? Nice, nice. Will's trying to date you. And I watched news like while eating dinner because, you know, it was better than actually talking to anybody. And so, but I never really thought I would do it. And I went to college and was,
你妈妈是谁？不错，不错。威尔想和你约会。我一边吃晚饭一边看新闻，因为，你知道，这比真正和任何人说话要好。所以，但我从来没想过我会做这个。我上了大学，并且是，
I actually interned at the CIA and I decided not to do that. What? What? And I- He knew we were gonna ask about that. All the stuff I was interested in was going overseas and experiencing stuff. And so, yeah, I made a fake,
我实际上在中央情报局实习过，我决定不那样做。什么？什么？而且我——他知道我们会问那个。我感兴趣的所有事情都是去海外体验事物。所以，是的，我做了一个假的，
I had a friend make a fake press pass for me and I borrowed a camera and I started going to wars. No way. That's so crazy. Wow, really? No way. What was fascinating about, what was fascinating about that to you?
我让一个朋友为我做了一个假的新闻证，我借了一台摄像机，我开始去战争地区。不会吧。那太疯狂了。哇，真的吗？不会吧。关于，关于那个，什么让你着迷？
Like, I always find that fascinating, like just from a viewer is like, why do they have to stand in the war zone? Can't they just tell us about it from somewhere safe? Actually, no, I like, you do, I mean, there's nothing, nothing can compare to actually being in a place. But like, but also like when they're standing
就像，我总是觉得那很迷人，就像从观众的角度来看，为什么他们必须站在战区？他们不能在安全的地方告诉我们吗？其实，不，我喜欢，你确实，我的意思是，没有什么能比得上真正身处一个地方。但就像，当他们站在
in the middle of a hurricane, forget the war, but we're standing in the middle of a hurricane. You don't have to do that. Yeah, we can just see that it's bad outside. You know, it's funny, when news organizations, when a big news story breaks and you go and I've seen you at so many,
飓风中心时，别提战争了，但我们站在飓风中心。你没必要那样做。是的，我们可以看到外面很糟糕。你知道，很有趣，当新闻机构，当一个大新闻爆发时，你去，我在很多地方见过你，
they've been hurricanes or big wars or whatever, you've done it all, we've all seen you, America, the world has seen you there. But it is funny when some big event happens, the race for news people to get on site is kind of like when someone famous dies and go to Wikipedia to see who writes it
它们是飓风或大战争或其他什么，你都做过，我们都见过你，美国，世界都见过你在那里。但当一些大事件发生时，新闻人员赶往现场的竞赛确实有点像某位名人去世，然后去维基百科看谁先在他们的页面上写下
on their page first. It's like this. Who's fastest to make it about them? Yeah. Well, no, not about them. I actually mean more like just to get there. Like I'm always surprised. It almost. On the scene.
它。就像这样。谁最快把它变成关于他们自己的？是的。好吧，不，不是关于他们自己。我其实是指更多就像只是为了到达那里。就像我总是很惊讶。几乎。在现场。
Yeah, I can't believe it. Like, so that's my followup question is, what happens, Russia invades Ukraine, let's say, or something of that, how quickly does that decision get made? Like you're, I don't know, you're at the gym. You might not even be at work or you're with your family. And then all of a sudden you're,
是的，我不敢相信。所以这是我的后续问题，发生了什么，俄罗斯入侵乌克兰，假设，或者类似的事情，那个决定做得有多快？就像你，我不知道，你在健身房。你甚至可能不在工作，或者你和家人在一起。然后突然你，
is it 30 seconds and you're out the door? Basically, yeah. I mean, I have like a go bag and I keep my passport with me at all times. Like a bat signal, but it's the Cooper signal. What's in the go bag? Yeah, what is it? How many pairs of underwear?
是30秒你就出门了吗？基本上，是的。我的意思是，我有一个应急包，我随时带着护照。就像蝙蝠信号，但它是库珀信号。应急包里有什么？是的，是什么？多少双内衣？
Like two. Underwear is not important. Hey, there he is. Not fair. Hey, man. I'm taking, bro. Come on. So it's just, it's just two pair.
就像两双。内衣不重要。嘿，他就在那儿。不公平。嘿，伙计。我正在拿，兄弟。拜托。所以只有两双。
God. It's just two pair? Yeah. I mean, these, but. Do you really have something, like, are you prepared to go in with it? There's like, there's a pair, I'll tell you, there's like a pair of boots,
天哪。只有两双？是的。我的意思是，这些，但是。你真的有什么东西，比如，你准备好带着它进去了吗？有，比如，有一双靴子，
steel-toed boots. Sure. There's, you know, like, it's mostly like food supplies, some like technical stuff. The clothes are like, you know, there's like two pairs, two dark t-shirts so you can sweat and not see nothing.
钢头靴。当然。有，你知道，比如，它主要是食物供应，一些技术性的东西。衣服就像，你知道，有两双，两件深色T恤，这样你可以出汗而看不出来。
But really, truly, are you really prepared to go at like any moment? Like, do you really have a bag type of thing ready? I do, yeah. He's just got to go back. It's crazy, yeah. Sean's got to go back. It's got two pounds of Skittles
但真的，真的，你真的准备好随时出发了吗？比如，你真的有一个包之类的东西准备好了吗？我有，是的。他只是有一个应急包。太疯狂了，是的。肖恩有一个应急包。它有两磅彩虹糖
and 50 little small things of soy sauce. Hey, Anderson, do you have a Dopp kit in there? By the way, we're going to ask you to follow up if you know where Dopp kit came from. But do you have a Dopp kit in there? A Dopp kit? What is it, Dopp? Dopp kit, Dopp kit.
和50个小包装的酱油。嘿，安德森，你里面有洗漱包吗？顺便说一句，如果你知道洗漱包是从哪里来的，我们会让你跟进。但你里面有洗漱包吗？洗漱包？那是什么，Dopp？洗漱包，洗漱包。
Yeah, that's not what people call it, Will. That's why. They do call it a Dopp. It's a toiletry bag. It's not toiletry bag. It's called a Dopp kit. I'm not, I feel like a toiletry bag is a step of adulthood like Galash's or an umbrella,
是的，那不是人们叫它的名字，威尔。这就是原因。他们确实叫它Dopp。它是一个洗漱袋。它不是洗漱袋。它叫洗漱包。我不，我觉得洗漱袋是成年的一步，就像套鞋或雨伞，
which I'm not ready to commit to. Well, what do you call it? I'm not that organized. You don't have like what you call a toiletry bag? I don't have a bag, but I just put stuff in, like it's all free-floating in my bag. In a CVS bag? Hang on, hang on a sec.
我还没准备好承诺。好吧，你叫它什么？我没那么有条理。你没有所谓的洗漱袋吗？我没有包，但我只是把东西放进去，就像它在我的包里自由漂浮。在CVS袋子里？等等，等等，等一下。
You got your tooth, wait a minute. It's messy. Your toothbrush is banging around with the steel toes? Yeah. That's outrageous. This is a disaster. Okay, in all honesty, there's a pocket in the like the Doppel bag
你有你的牙齿，等一下。它很乱。你的牙刷和钢头靴撞在一起？是的。那太离谱了。这是一场灾难。好吧，老实说，在洗漱包里有一个口袋
that I put like all that stuff in, but it's all just floating around in that pocket. Yeah. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. So none of that scares the shit out of you. Like what is the draw? What is the thing inside of you that's like,
我把所有那些东西都放进去，但它们只是在那个口袋里漂浮。是的。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。所以所有这些都不会把你吓坏吗？比如吸引力是什么？你内心深处的东西是什么，就像，
I gotta get to the middle of where everybody's shooting guns and bowling at bombs. It comes from a really healthy place. I'll tell you that. I mean, honestly, the honest answer, I mean, I don't want to bring it down, but yeah, my dad died when I was a kid. My brother died by suicide when I was 21, he was 23.
我必须到达每个人都在开枪和扔炸弹的地方。它来自一个非常健康的地方。我告诉你。我的意思是，老实说，诚实的答案，我的意思是，我不想让它变得低落，但是的，我爸爸在我小时候去世了。我哥哥在21岁时自杀身亡，他当时23岁。
And I wanted to go places where the language of loss was spoken, where when you are feeling grief and dealing with loss and don't really know how to deal with it and you want to be around other people who are facing it and living through it and where it's not, where it's something people talk about and are living and it's very real.
我想去那些说失落语言的地方，当你感到悲伤并处理失落，不知道如何处理它，你想和那些面对它并经历它的人在一起，在那里它不是，在那里它是人们谈论并正在生活的东西，而且非常真实。
Here, people don't talk about that stuff and it makes it worse if you're suffering. Did you know that before you went, or is this something that in retrospect you kind of understand? No, I was pretty aware. I mean, I didn't connect all the dots. Initially, I just had this impulse of like,
在这里，人们不谈论那些事情，如果你在受苦，这会让情况变得更糟。你在去之前知道这一点吗，还是这是你事后才理解的事情？不，我很清楚。我的意思是，我没有把所有的点连起来。最初，我只是有这种冲动，就像，
I drawn to, and mostly places where people are suffering that wasn't getting a lot of attention, that was sort of, the first place I went was Burma. I snuck into Burma and hooked up with some students fighting the Burmese government in the jungles and I shot a story of them. And then I ended up in Somalia in the early days of famine before the US got there
我被吸引，主要是人们正在受苦且没有得到太多关注的地方，那有点像，我去的第一个地方是缅甸。我溜进缅甸，和一些在丛林中与缅甸政府作战的学生联系在一起，我拍摄了他们的故事。然后我最终在92年8月饥荒初期到达了索马里，在美军到达之前
and the whole Black Hawk Down thing happened. It was in August of 92. And I was just drawn to places where, yeah, where people were suffering and where I, I mean, I wanted to tell their story. I wanted other people to know about it, but I also wanted to learn how to survive. Did it heal you?
整个黑鹰坠落事件发生了。我只是被吸引到那些，是的，人们正在受苦的地方，在那里我，我的意思是，我想讲述他们的故事。我想让其他人知道它，但我也想学习如何生存。它治愈了你吗？
I don't know about healing, but it, I learned I could survive and I learned how to survive from a lot of people I met. And I learned a lot about myself and a lot about other people and the power of people to get through the worst things that I've ever happened to them. Things which I don't think I could personally survive.
我不知道关于治愈，但它，我学会了我可以生存，我从我遇到的很多人那里学会了如何生存。我学到了很多关于我自己和很多关于其他人以及人们克服他们经历过的最糟糕事情的力量。那些我认为我个人无法生存的事情。
You know, people who have had horrific things done to them and every day get up and take care of their children and hold their head up high and in the face of it. It's like, and to that point, you touched on this a little bit. Like what is that culture shock from going to these other countries and then coming back to the United States
你知道，那些经历过可怕事情的人，每天起床照顾他们的孩子，在面对它时昂首挺胸。就像，说到这一点，你稍微触及了这一点。就像从去这些其他国家然后回到美国的那种文化冲击是什么
where people are like, you know, the most mundane issues. Like, I mean, we have real issues here, but what I'm saying compared to other countries. Yeah, I actually lived in L.A. When I first started, I was working for this thing called Channel One. It was seen in schools throughout America in the early 90s.
人们就像，你知道，最平凡的问题。我的意思是，我们这里有真正的问题，但我想说的是与其他国家相比。是的，我其实住在洛杉矶。我刚开始的时候，我为这个叫Channel One的东西工作。它在90年代初在全美的学校里播放。
And it was in about half the schools. In America, it was a 12 minute daily newscast and I was like their foreign correspondent person. And I would come back to L.A., which is where it was based at Raleigh Studios, weirdly enough. And I just remember I was briefly in Rwanda during the genocide and I'd gone from the elections in South Africa for Mandela,
它在大约一半的学校里。在美国，这是一个12分钟的每日新闻广播，我就像他们的外国记者。我会回到洛杉矶，也就是它总部所在地，奇怪的是在罗利制片厂。我只记得我在卢旺达种族灭绝期间短暂地待过，我从南非曼德拉的选举中回来，
which was incredible to this horrific genocide in Rwanda. And I came back to L.A. And I just felt like I couldn't speak the same language as people and all I wanted to do was kind of just get on a plane and go somewhere else again. Yeah. Well, because it's real.
那真是令人难以置信，到卢旺达那场可怕的种族灭绝。我回到洛杉矶。我只是觉得我无法和人们说同样的语言，我只想做的就是坐上飞机再去别的地方。是的。好吧，因为它是真实的。
I mean, there's, it must feel very real or in some, to some degree, more real than what's going on. I mean, you're there dealing with this stuff and Sean's making a Bud Light commercial, you know? Back in the 90s. I mean, honestly, sorry, Sean, and you should be ashamed of yourself by this shameful. And I'm sure you are riddled with shame.
我的意思是，有，它一定感觉非常真实，或者在某种程度上，比正在发生的事情更真实。我的意思是，你在那里处理这些事情，而肖恩在拍百威淡啤广告，你知道吗？回到90年代。我的意思是，老实说，对不起，肖恩，你应该为此感到羞耻，这太可耻了。我相信你充满了羞耻。
But no, but in truth though, I mean, that's a very, for a young man who's trying to process a lot of stuff, that's very, very heavy. And in a lot of way, you know what you're doing. You're subjecting yourself to it and you also know that you're doing it at the same time. Like there must have been a couple, you're kind of of two minds while it's happening.
但不，但说真的，我的意思是，对于一个试图处理很多事情的年轻人来说，那非常，非常沉重。在很多方面，你知道你在做什么。你让自己经历它，同时你也知道你在做它。就像一定有几个，当它发生时，你有两种想法。
Yes, no? No, that's 100%. And yeah, it makes regular life seem very dull and it's hard to return back to a regular life with that. All you want to do is kind of go back out. But when you're out, you're miserable and lonely and sad and it's horrific stuff around you and people are, you know, you're meeting people
是的，不？不，那是100%。而且是的，它让正常生活看起来非常枯燥，很难带着那个回到正常生活。你只想做的就是回到外面。但当你在外面时，你很痛苦、孤独、悲伤，你周围都是可怕的事情，人们是，你知道，你正在遇见
who are stuck in these situations and you're gonna leave and that brings with it, it's all, it's its own sort of weirdness. Were there any complications or concerns about going into those areas given the family that you were coming from? Did you get any resistance from that, from your family or lawyers or somebody like,
那些被困在这些情况中的人，而你要离开，这带来了它自己的某种奇怪之处。考虑到你来自的家庭，去那些地区有什么并发症或担忧吗？你有没有从那，从你的家人或律师或某人那里得到任何阻力，比如，
hey, Anderson, hold on a second. You get kidnapped in this area. Like there's, I mean, seriously. No, no, my mom was actually amazingly supportive of it. I mean, she was alone and she was just her and I at that point and she was really cool about it. I mean, I sort of lied to her a lot early on. I'd be like, oh yeah, no, it's not so bad.
嘿，安德森，等一下。你在那个地区被绑架了。就像有，我的意思是，说真的。不，不，我妈妈其实非常支持它。我的意思是，她当时很孤独，那时只有她和我，她对此真的很酷。我的意思是，我早期经常对她撒谎。我会说，哦，是的，不，没那么糟。
It's not so bad, it's not so bad like you see on TV when they exaggerate. I was in Egypt during the revolution against Mubarak and got attacked and I'd call my mom that morning and I was like, no, I'm just gonna stay by the pool today and hang out and of course, like there was no pool and I would not be staying by it. Wait, Anderson, can we go to Egypt?
没那么糟，没那么糟，不像你在电视上看到的那样，他们夸大了。我在埃及反对穆巴拉克的革命期间，被袭击了，那天早上我给我妈妈打电话，我说，不，我今天就待在游泳池边，闲逛，当然，就像没有游泳池，我也不会待在它旁边。等等，安德森，我们可以去埃及吗？
Is it safe? You too, sure. I mean, I don't know, it's a little late, but you can't be good with that. Yeah, Scotty wants to go really, we wanna really go really bad. I mean, you know, it's not great for the gays, I gotta tell you.
安全吗？你们两个，当然。我的意思是，我不知道，有点晚了，但你不能那样做。是的，斯科蒂真的很想去，我们真的很想去。我的意思是，你知道，对同性恋来说不太好，我得告诉你。
I know that's what I heard, that's really hard. I mean, there's, well, I don't wanna, I mean. So we'll just call each other roommate. Yeah, is that right? I mean, you, I don't know, you're a well-known, but I mean, that brings with it, it's the one thing, like, you know, like, yeah, I'm not sure, you're a very well-known gay person.
我知道那就是我听到的，那真的很难。我的意思是，有，好吧，我不想，我的意思是。所以我们只会称对方为室友。是的，是这样吗？我的意思是，你，我不知道，你是一个众所周知的，但我的意思是，这带来了它，这是一件事，就像，你知道，就像，是的，我不确定，你是一个非常著名的同性恋者。
Can you go? You know, I got beat up there, so I haven't been back since I got beat up, but. That's a great line of questioning, Sean. Wait, Anderson. By the way, triple, triple the number. I just wanna visit the pyramids, that's all. Now, Anderson, the stuff you've seen over there,
你能去吗？你知道，我在那里被打过，所以我被打之后就没回去过，但是。那是一个很好的提问方式，肖恩。等等，安德森。顺便说一句，三倍，三倍的数量。我只是想参观金字塔，仅此而已。现在，安德森，你在那边看到的东西，
being all brave as you are, witnessing all of this stuff, is it, do you have a certain muscle that you've developed to sort of shed all those horrible things that could really wreck some folks, as far as visuals and memories and PTSD, and you've really been in a lot of tough spots. I don't, I don't think you, like, I think the job is to sort of bear witness to stuff,
像你一样勇敢，目睹所有这些事情，是吗，你是否有一种肌肉，你已经发展出一种肌肉来摆脱所有那些可能真正摧毁一些人的可怕事情，就视觉和记忆和创伤后应激障碍而言，你确实在很多艰难的地方待过。我，我不认为你，就像，我认为工作是某种见证事情，
and I think if you, if you don't allow yourself to be moved by it and changed by it, and if you're like this cold observer with a distance, you're not doing justice to the people who are there, and I think you need to expose yourself to it all. And so, yeah. Yeah, especially if your job is to relay that story to other folks.
我认为如果你，如果你不允许自己被它感动和改变，如果你像这个带着距离的冷漠观察者，你对那里的人是不公平的，我认为你需要让自己接触到这一切。所以，是的。是的，特别是如果你的工作是把那个故事转达给其他人。
Yeah, totally. To Jason's point, though, like, don't you, I mean, all of that stuff that is now that you can't unsee, that you've seen all these horrible things in the world, how does that affect you and your family now going forward? Like, what is one of the greatest things you learned in your journalism, you know, abroad, that you now apply to your family,
是的，完全。不过，说到杰森的观点，就像，难道你不，我的意思是，所有那些现在你无法忘记的东西，你已经在世界上看到了所有这些可怕的事情，这怎么影响你和你的家人现在向前看？就像，你在新闻工作中，你知道，在国外学到的最伟大的事情之一是什么，你现在应用到你的家庭，
and or what do you try to withhold from your family, your kids? I mean, I think it shows you to embrace the beautiful moments that are possible in one's life and the extraordinary, I mean, the fact that I, as a gay man, can have children in this country, and we can marry if we want to, and I'm married,
或者你试图对你的家人，你的孩子隐瞒什么？我的意思是，我认为它向你展示了拥抱一个人生活中可能的美好时刻和非凡，我的意思是，事实上，作为一个同性恋者，我可以在这个国家有孩子，如果我们愿意，我们可以结婚，而且我结婚了，
but you appreciate all the more what there is, and you appreciate the kind of the moments of beauty and joy and love that you do actually find. Yeah, I love that. So then as a follow-up, and you see all this, we talk about all this horrible stuff that you've seen in your journalistic career overseas, or whatever, traumatic things, et cetera,
但你更欣赏所拥有的一切，你欣赏你确实找到的那种美丽、快乐和爱的时刻。是的，我喜欢那个。所以作为一个后续，你看到了这一切，我们谈论了你在海外新闻生涯中看到的所有这些可怕的事情，或者无论什么，创伤性事情，等等，
and then you're able to appreciate the fact that you have these freedoms that you enjoy as an American here in America. Are you worried about now, conversely, about seeing horrible things in this country, and we've all sort of been able to bear witness to a lot of a pretty darkened shift that seems rather dark as a newer American
然后你能够欣赏这样一个事实，即你拥有作为美国人在美国享受的这些自由。你现在担心，相反，在这个国家看到可怕的事情吗，我们所有人都能够见证很多相当黑暗的转变，这看起来相当黑暗，作为一个较新的美国人
than the three of you, that I find to be quite troubling and dark, and you talk about the freedom as a gay man to have kids and to be married, if you choose. We are entering a very dark age, and as a newsman, you've been right on the front line of it. Yeah, look, I mean, I'm optimistic about this country, and I'm optimistic about the people in this country,
比你们三个，我觉得这相当令人不安和黑暗，你谈到了作为同性恋者有孩子和结婚的自由，如果你选择的话。我们正在进入一个非常黑暗的时代，作为新闻人，你一直处于它的最前线。是的，看，我的意思是，我对这个国家持乐观态度，我对这个国家的人民持乐观态度，
and I think we're going through a very strange time, and but I choose to believe in the best in people, and I think we go, we tack left, we tack right, but we've moved forward as a country, and I hope that continues. But I do think people are capable of anything. I think we're all capable of anything. I think we have no idea, you have no idea
我认为我们正在经历一个非常奇怪的时期，但我选择相信人们最好的一面，我认为我们走，我们向左转，我们向右转，但我们作为一个国家向前迈进了，我希望这种情况继续下去。但我确实认为人们有能力做任何事情。我认为我们都有能力做任何事情。我认为我们不知道，你不知道
what happens when the electricity goes out and there's no windows and you're building anymore, and the wind is whipping through it, and it's the winter, and you can't feed your kids, you can't get them milk, and people are capable of anything, and I've seen that, and that worries me. I don't mean left or right.
当电力中断，没有窗户，你不再是建筑，风在里面呼啸，那是冬天，你不能喂你的孩子，你不能给他们牛奶，人们有能力做任何事情，我见过，这让我担心。我不是指左或右。
I just mean in general, in terms of people, there's a sort of a sentiment that feels like it's very, there are some, there is a kind of a vibe that's nerve-wracking. I'll just put it that way. Yeah, but I'm with Anderson, and I'm sure you guys are too, that there's an optimism that is sort of impossible
我只是指总体而言，就人们而言，有一种感觉，感觉非常，有一些，有一种让人紧张的氛围。我只是这么说。是的，但我同意安德森，我相信你们也是，有一种乐观情绪，当你想到这个国家的整体以及我们之前经历过的所有事情时，这种乐观情绪是某种不可能
and not to feel when you just think of the totality of this country and all the things that we've been through before. This is not the first time we've gone through real growing pains and border-pushing, and I think we'll land just fine, I hope. And by the way, I've seen plenty of places that have fallen apart and societies that have collapsed.
而不去感受的。这不是我们第一次经历真正的成长痛苦和边界推动，我认为我们会落地得很好，我希望。顺便说一句，我见过很多分崩离析的地方和崩溃的社会。
I mean, that's what interested me initially in going to places like that, and it is horrible, and nobody, I mean, whatever rhetoric people are saying here, the reality of that, if they actually see it, they will not be pushing for any kind of civil war. I mean, it is, what happens is a horrible, horrible thing. Right, right, right.
我的意思是，这就是最初吸引我去那样的地方的原因，而且它很可怕，没有人，我的意思是，无论人们在这里说什么修辞，如果他们真的看到它，他们就不会推动任何形式的内战。我的意思是，它，发生的事情是一件非常，非常可怕的事情。对，对，对。
What are these, you know, like going back to the thing where you'd like have to drop everything at, you'd have to leave at the drop of a hat and pack and go to all these places. Don't you have to get like clearance and all this stuff, and everybody in the world knows who you are and they know that you're gay. So what about these countries where you have to go
这些是什么，你知道，回到你必须放下一切，你必须随时准备离开，打包去所有这些地方的事情。难道你不必获得许可和所有这些东西吗，世界上每个人都知道你是谁，他们知道你是同性恋。那么这些国家，你必须去
to report where they're like, oh God, the gay guy from that channel is coming, and he's got clearance, we gotta let him in. You know, is that, do you ever? Sometimes, I mean, clearance is like visas sometime in some places, but for the most part, you just get on a plane and go and figure it out once you get there.
报道，他们就像，哦天哪，那个频道的同性恋家伙要来了，他有许可，我们得让他进来。你知道，是那个吗，你曾经吗？有时，我的意思是，许可就像在某些地方的签证，但大多数情况下，你只是坐上飞机去，一旦你到达那里就弄清楚。
And yeah, I mean, initially I was traveling all by myself to Jason's point earlier, and that was, you know, ridiculously risky and stupid in a lot of places I was going. You know, in some places we have security, but it's, you know, it's a concern. I mean, it's definitely changed the security situation when I'm on the ground in places. The CNN thankfully is very cognizant of that,
而且是的，我的意思是，最初我是一个人旅行，回到杰森之前的观点，那，你知道，在很多我去的地方是非常冒险和愚蠢的。你知道，在某些地方我们有安全保障，但它，你知道，这是一个担忧。我的意思是，当我身处各地时，它绝对改变了安全状况。CNN值得庆幸的是非常清楚这一点，
but for the most part, you know, you have to go, I mean, I want to go still and you have to go and that's just part of the job. Yeah, so with your incredible position at CNN and at 60 minutes, you have the opportunity, I'm sure, to decide what stories you're going to do, things that are interesting to you that you might stumble upon or told about,
但大多数情况下，你知道，你必须去，我的意思是，我仍然想去，你必须去，这只是工作的一部分。是的，所以凭借你在CNN和《60分钟》的不可思议的职位，我相信你有机会决定你要做什么故事，那些对你来说有趣的事情，你可能会偶然发现或被告知，
how do you decide which show to do the story for? How does that work? I mean, for the most part, you know, 60 minutes is, I do like 10 stories a year. The average correspondent does 20, so I do like a half load. And the, yeah, it's just stuff that interests me. And some of it is producers suggesting it.
你是如何决定为哪个节目做报道的？这套流程是怎么运作的？我的意思是，在很大程度上，你知道，《60分钟》我一年大概做10个报道。普通记者一年做20个，所以我相当于只承担了一半的工作量。而且，是的，这纯粹是因为那些题材让我感兴趣。有时是制片人建议的。
Other times, you know, other times it's, I did a profile of Tony Bennett, you know, who was having his final concerts with Lady Gaga. And his family let us spend the, you know, months before the concert, leading up to it with Tony in his apartment and going through what he's going through. And so, I mean, that was, you know,
其他时候，你知道，比如我曾为托尼·班内特做过人物专访，当时他正和Lady Gaga举行最后的巡回演唱会。他的家人让我们在演唱会前的几个月里，陪着托尼待在他的公寓里，记录他所经历的一切。所以，我的意思是，那真是……
the chance to do that is just incredible. I got to, I got to, I had a piece on recently about this artist, Laurie Anderson, who I've loved since I was a teenager. Yes. She came out with the song, Oh Superman. And she's just cool. She's 75 and a lot of people don't know who she is.
能有这样的机会真是太不可思议了。我最近还做了一篇关于艺术家劳瑞·安德森的报道，我从十几岁起就一直很喜欢她。没错。她当时出了一首叫《Oh Superman》的歌。她真的很酷。她今年75岁了，很多人都不知道她是谁。
And so, it's so cool to be able to be like, you know, Laurie Anderson's really interesting. Let's do a story. And 60 minutes is like, yeah, okay, sure. And so it doesn't have to be someone who has a movie or out, it can just be somebody who's kind of interesting. And that's amazing. I love that.
所以，能说出“劳瑞·安德森真的很有趣，我们来做个报道吧”这种话真的很酷。《60分钟》的反应是：“好啊，没问题。”所以报道对象不一定非得是那种有电影要上映的人，也可以只是一个有趣的人。这太棒了，我喜欢这样。
What happens if you get yourself a guest either on 60 minutes or on 360? And they're just not really giving you the answers that you either want to hear or that you know are correct. I hate the burning fire of a thousand songs. But you're so, you're so, you're a good dude. A good dude that you can just, you can see it. And so being confrontational is something
如果你在《60分钟》或《360度》节目中请到了一位嘉宾，而他们给出的答案并不是你想听的，或者你知道是不正确的，你会怎么办？我讨厌那种咄咄逼人的质问。但你是个好人，一个能让人看出来的好人。所以，咄咄逼人这种事……
that I'm sure you're not that comfortable with, but it is part of your job. How do you reconcile those two things? Well, I mean, if someone's just not a good guest, I'm not gonna be confrontational with them because they're not a good guest. Although I do know a producer once, a producer at 60 Minutes once, I was with him in Niger.
我相信你并不习惯，但这毕竟是你的工作。你是如何调和这两者的？嗯，我的意思是，如果某人本身就不是个好嘉宾，我不会对他咄咄逼人，因为他本来就表现不好。不过，我确实认识一位制片人，在《60分钟》工作时，有一次我和他在尼日尔。
And it was like a malnutrition crisis. And we had flown all the way there and we're doing the story about this thing called Plumpy Nut which is saving the lives of thousands, hundreds of thousands of kids over the years. Anyway, we go and we interviewed this doctor and it's just not going well. And like we've come all this way
当时那里正发生营养不良危机。我们大老远飞过去，做关于一种叫“Plumpy Nut”的营养膏的报道，这种东西多年来拯救了成千上万、几十万儿童的生命。总之，我们去采访了一位医生，但采访进行得并不顺利。我们大老远跑来……
and like we thought she was the character, but it's just not going well. And I try everything I can do. I, you know, all the little interviewing techniques, none of it works. Finally, the producer goes, you know what, you're like a boring professor from a class no one wants to take.
我们本以为她会是个很有故事的人，但采访就是不顺利。我尝试了所有能用的办法，你知道，所有那些采访技巧，但都没用。最后，制片人说：“你知道吗，你就像个没人想上的课的无聊教授。”
And I was like, okay, I think we're done here. I think. That's what the woman said? No, no, that's where the producer said to the woman and he was trying to like jump start, he was trying to like put the pads on her and like jump start her heart. It killed it.
我当时心想，好吧，我想我们到此为止了。我想。那是那个女人说的？不，不，那是制片人对那个女人说的，他当时试图刺激她，就像给心脏骤停的人用电击除颤器一样，想重启她的心脏。这招确实奏效了。
And like, yeah, we ended up, you know, we saved the story. But so yeah, but I, that's not something I would ever say to somebody. But yeah, confrontation is not something I have a tradition of, but I will say, I've gotten to the point where I'm very comfortable in fronting people if they are not telling the truth, because it really pisses me off
是的，我们最终挽救了那个报道。但说真的，那不是我会对别人说的话。不过，我确实要说，我已经到了那种如果对方在撒谎，我会非常从容地当面拆穿他们的地步，因为当有人撒谎时，我真的会很生气。
when someone's not telling the truth. Yeah, but that necessitates you being as aware of the facts as this politician might. And that then I, my next question is, where do you find the time to be as educated as you need to be to do your job as well as you do it? So ideally, if you're doing an interview like that, that you know is going to be confrontational,
是的，但这需要你像那位政客一样了解事实。那么我的下一个问题是，你从哪里找时间去学习，从而达到你现在这种专业水准的？所以理想情况下，如果你要进行一场你知道会充满对抗性的采访……
I mean, I spend hours reading, I try to read like everything that person has said, if you know it's going to be confrontational, if you know that they have stated things which are not true and you know, you want to zero in on it, you zero on in just a few points, and I try to read everything they've said
我的意思是，我会花几个小时阅读，我尽量阅读那个人说过的一切。如果你知道采访会充满对抗性，如果你知道他们曾发表过不实言论，而你想抓住这一点，你就要锁定几个关键点，我尽量阅读他们……
over the last like six months or six weeks, at least, because generally people repeat themselves over and over. So you can see in multiple interviews what somebody has already said, and then you know, okay, they're going to make, they're going to tell this lie, and then you have all the facts backed up. So if you, you know, if you do your research,
过去六个月或六周内说过的一切，因为通常人们会反复重复同样的话。所以你可以在多次采访中看出某人已经说过什么，然后你就知道，好吧，他们打算撒这个谎，然后你就有所有事实作为支撑。所以如果你做了研究……
you have the advantage of knowing what they're going to say sometimes, and if they fall into that trap, then you can just say, okay, well, actually, here's the facts here, according to this organization, this organization, and there's nothing more satisfying than that. Yeah, you got the real silk glove and you do that.
你有时会占据优势，因为你知道他们会说什么。如果他们掉进那个陷阱，你就可以直接说：“好吧，实际上，根据这个组织和那个组织的数据，事实是这样的。”没有什么比这更令人满足的了。没错，你用那种“丝绒手套”的方式做到了。
Yeah, then burning somebody on TV. Well, it's not even so much burning them on TV, it's more just like just stating facts to somebody who has, because most people are doing interviews, you know, they pop up on the screen, they don't have the facts with them, so they can't really challenge somebody. So if you have the time to actually do the research,
是的，比起在电视上让对方难堪，更多的是向那些撒谎的人陈述事实。因为大多数人做采访时，你知道，他们突然出现在屏幕上，并没有准备好事实，所以他们无法真正挑战对方。所以如果你有时间去做研究……
there's nothing more satisfying than that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Will wants to know where you get your news from. He always asks a journalist, where he thinks that there's like some- This is abatement, he's trying to cover up his own, he's always like, you get, the journalists have some secret channel of news.
没有什么比这更令人满足的了。是的，是的，是的。威尔想知道你的新闻来源。他总是问记者，他觉得好像有什么……这是在推卸责任，他想掩盖自己的……他总是觉得记者有什么秘密的新闻渠道。
Where do the news reporters get their news, if not from- They're reporting on the stuff that's happening, Dougie. Okay, where did Maggie Haberman get her information from after some of the sources? She wouldn't have interviewed people. Maggie Haberman has contacts that she has developed over the years, or whenever, and she contacts them
新闻记者如果不是从……那他们从哪得到新闻？他们报道的是正在发生的事情，道基。好吧，玛吉·哈伯曼在采访了一些消息源后，是从哪里得到信息的？她总得采访别人吧。玛吉·哈伯曼有她多年来建立的人脉，或者无论什么时候，她都会联系他们……
and she breaks news and then other people, sometimes people report what Maggie Haberman has said or we report the times it said, or we have folks at CNN who have the sources and that's what you either talk to people directly or- What do you think that Maggie Haberman's up in her bedroom, like fucking copying USA Today with her feet up in the air? Maggie, dinner's ready to hang on,
然后她发布新闻，接着其他人，有时人们会报道玛吉·哈伯曼所说的，或者我们报道《时报》所说的，或者我们在CNN有消息源，这就是你直接与人交谈的方式，或者……你以为玛吉·哈伯曼在卧室里，翘着脚抄《今日美国》吗？“玛吉，晚饭好了。”“等一下，我正在写明天的新闻，我正从别人那抄呢。”你在干什么？但安德森，安德森没有……他不是像哈尔·霍尔布鲁克和玛吉·哈伯曼那样在地下停车场接头。我不是在海湖庄园的大厅里和……对，所以他有一个很棒的团队，问号和……
I'm just writing out my fucking story for tomorrow that I'm copying from another, what are you doing? But Anderson, Anderson is, he doesn't have, like he's not down in the underground parking lot, like Hal Hallbrook and Maggie Haberman. I'm not in the hall as the Mar-a-Lago talking to- Right, yeah, so like, so he's got an incredible staff, question mark and-
（接上文）所以，是的，对于CNN来说，我有一个大约30人的团队，但我们有所有这些记者可以依靠，还有所有这些嘉宾可以依靠。玛吉·哈伯曼是CNN的撰稿人，所以我们可以请她来谈谈她发布的新闻。所以你今晚有个节目要录，我想……
So yeah, so I've got, you know, for CNN here, you know, I've got a team of like 30 people and, but we have all these correspondents to rely on and all these guests to rely on and Maggie Haberman is a contributor to CNN and so we can bring her on and talk about what she's broken. So you've got a show tonight you're about to do, so I'd imagine, so you've got,
我们很快就会让你走，所以你可能会和一个大房间里的那30名员工在一起，他们会说：“这是今天发生的事，这是你应该知道的。”是吗？是的，我的意思是，这发生在早上，所以我们现在是在东海岸的傍晚时分，所以那是今天早些时候发生的……
we're gonna let you go here soon and so you're gonna get in probably a big room with those 30 staff members and they're gonna say, here's what happened today, here's what you should know and yes? Yeah, I mean, this happens in the morning, so it's, we're talking in the almost evening on the East Coast and so that happened early this morning
关于“我们的记者在哪里，我们认为会发生什么？”但事情全天都在变化，甚至在我们直播时也在变。所以你基本上必须整天都在阅读。我喜欢阅读，我喜欢学习新东西，所以你整天都在阅读……
of like, okay, we're our correspondents, what do we think is gonna happen? But stuff changes all throughout the day and even while we're on the air, stuff changes and so what you have to do basically is you have to just read stuff all day long. So I like reading, I like learning stuff, so you just read stuff all day long
这样在节目进行到一半时，当你以为会是最后45分钟的内容因为突发事件被推翻时，你脑子里已经有了足够的知识，即使没有提词器，没有嘉宾，什么都没有，你也能谈上45分钟，因为你读了很多书。
so that in the middle of the program when what you think is gonna be the 45 minutes, the last 45 minutes of your show, gets tossed out because something else has happened, you already know enough in your head that you can talk about that for 45 minutes even if there's no teleprompter and there's no guests, there's nothing, you just have done a lot of reading.
那太可怕了。没错，所以当发生某事时，比如杰森，某人被起诉了，或者其他什么，那个故事发布了，他们发表了声明，书记员做了什么，无论是什么，和安德森一起工作的男男女女，把所有这些东西给他，然后他们根据这些事实发展出一个故事……
That's so scary. Right, so like when there's something happens, let's say Jason, there's something, the so-and-so was indicted or whatever, that story is released, they make a statement, the clerks do whoever, whatever and the guys who work and women, everybody who works with Anderson, give them all that stuff and then they develop a story
你这个该死的白痴。不，但这确实很有趣，就像那种层层传递，所有在现场的人获取故事，然后汇报给这个人，然后复述，最后传到你这里，然后你把它播出来。没错，但直播电视最有趣的是，你正在直播……
based on those facts, you fucking idiot. No, but it is kind of interesting like the trickle down like all the people on the ground getting the story and then reports to this person and then reprises it and then it finally gets to you and then you put it on the air. Right, but the most interesting thing for a live television is you're on the air
然后发生了什么事，上帝保佑，比如飞机坠毁，而你只有几句信息，你知道航班号，你知道起飞时间，你知道它要去哪里，所以你进入滚动报道模式。这意味着控制室里的每个人，突然间就像全员出动，他们开始打电话给飞行专家、航空专家……
and something happens, God forbid a plane crashes and all you have are a few sentences of information, you know the flight number, you know what time it took off, you know where it was supposed to go and so you go into rolling coverage and that means that everyone who's in the control room, it's suddenly like all hands on deck, they start calling flight experts, aviation experts,
任何他们能想到的人，交通部长、交通部、国家运输安全委员会的人，无论是什么。在直播中，你开始转述信息，指出你不知道的部分，并进行一场持续的对话，可能持续30秒，也可能持续9个小时。
anybody they can possibly think of, somebody from the Secretary of Transportation, the Department of Transportation, the MTSB, whatever it is. And on air, you start relaying the information, you point out what you don't know and you have an ongoing conversation that can go from anywhere from 30 seconds, you can be on for nine hours.
当你把这一切从脑子里清空，想要放松时，你会做什么？你和孩子们玩吗？你看什么？我是个神经绷得最紧的人。你做什么来放松？你开始看安迪·科恩的那些节目，然后你吃了一堆软糖，会发生什么？
What are you doing when you get rid of all this out of your head and just to like check out, what are you doing with the kids, you're playing with the kids, what are you watching? I'm the most tightly wound person there is. What do you do to unwind? You start watching some of the Andy Cohen stuff and you just take you in a bunch of gummies,
不，这听起来完全像是在拍你马屁。我发现，我回家后会看那些能让我完全从脑子和世界里抽离出来的东西。比如《黑钱胜地》，我着迷了，我爱死它了，我认为它是最伟大的剧集之一……
what happens? So no, so this is gonna sound totally like I'm sucking up to you. I find it, I watch, I go home and I watch stuff that completely takes me out of my head and out of my world. So like Ozark, for instance, I am obsessed, I have loved it, I think it's one of the greatest shows,
不，是电视史上最伟大的剧集之一。它让我完全从自己的思绪中跳出来，进入另一个世界，我觉得这很放松。我觉得《黑钱胜地》很放松，《毒枭》也很放松。哦，是的。比如《格莫拉》，我不知道你有没有看过《格莫拉》。当然。它是最棒的，太神奇了。
no, one of the greatest shows in television. And it so takes me out of my head and into this other world, I find it relaxing. I found Ozark relaxing, I found Narcos relaxing. Oh yeah. Like Gamora, which is, I don't know if you've seen Gamora. Of course. It is the greatest, it's amazing.
但《黑钱胜地》，它太天才了，最后一季是天才之作，结局令人难以置信，整个过程都是。你太客气了，谢谢，我也很喜欢。是的，还有你的角色，我和你一样，心想：“哦，好吧，那个人刚被爆头了。好吧，那我们现在得做这个。好的，那我们就做那个。”这就是我处理一切的方式。
But Ozark, it was so genius and the last season was genius and the end was incredible, the whole thing. You're very nice, thank you, I love it too. Yeah, and your character, I'm the same way of like, oh, okay, that person just got shot in the head. Okay, so now we have to do this. All right, so let's do that. So that is how I deal with everything.
是的，一样，我有点……让我问问你关于《格莫拉》的事。你看过《奇罗》的衍生电影吗？我看过，但我不太喜欢。是的，我也不太喜欢。但你知道吗，我不想批评关于《格莫拉》的任何东西，因为我……我甚至没那么喜欢那部电影，但《格莫拉》本身……
Yeah, same, I'm a little bit of a... Let me ask you about Gamora. Did you see the Chiro spin-off movie? I did, I didn't love it. Yeah, I didn't love it either. But you know what, I don't want to criticize anything about Gamora, because I just, I didn't even like the movie, Gamora so much.
那部电视剧，我只能说，太震撼了。你，我不是要跟你比，安德森，我觉得你很棒。哦，天哪。你看过原著吗？我看过，其实。是的，很棒。书很棒。
The TV show, I just, it's mind-blowing. Did you, and I'm not here to one-up you, Anderson, I think you're great. Oh boy. Did you read the book? I did, actually. Yeah, it's great. The book is great.
是的。罗伯托·萨维亚诺，写得太棒了。是的，他自从写了这些东西后就一直躲藏起来。我读过他的另一本书，他最近的一本书，我读了，但我没太看进去，但是……你读过那本吗，雷德威尔？我没有。
Yeah. Roberto Saviano, it's fucking great. Yeah, who's been in hiding ever since he wrote this stuff. I read his, he had another book, his most recent book I read, which I didn't really get into, but... Did you get that one, Redwell? I did not.
我没读过那本书。哦，你没读过？哦，哈，我寄给你。有趣，我们回来了，我们回来了。那么，现在新年，新年活动看起来好像让我放松了头发，放松了一点，思考一下，那是怎么来的？你主动请缨的吗？
I did not read the book. Oh, you didn't? Oh, huh, I'll send it to you. Interesting, and we're back, and we're back. So what, now the New Year's, the New Year's thing seems like I get the hair down, relax a little bit, think, how did that come about? Did you raise your hand for that?
是的，你得在CNN签多少份免责声明，才能说：“伙计，今年冷静点吧？”你知道，这很有趣，所以我已经做了大约……我开始自愿做新年节目是因为我讨厌除夕夜。我大约15年前开始自愿参加，因为CNN没人做这个，他们需要人……
Yeah, and how many releases do you have to sign into CNN just like, man, just fucking cool it this year? You know, it's funny, so I've been doing that for like, I just, I started volunteering to do New Year's because I hated New Year's Eve. I started volunteering like 15 years ago, because no one at CNN was doing it, and they needed somebody,
我就说：“我讨厌除夕夜，你没法玩，压力太大了。”纽约的俱乐部，排队太长了。没错。你最后还得和喝醉的女孩抢出租车。所以我说：“你知道吗，我除夕夜干脆工作吧。”而且我以前从未在除夕夜去过时代广场……
and I was like, I hate New Year's Eve, you can't have fun, there's too much pressure. Clubs in New York, like there's too many long lines. Right. You end up fighting over cabs with drunk girls. So I was like, you know what, I'll just work on New Year's Eve, and I'd never been in Times Square's on New Year's Eve,
结果发现我其实真的很喜欢它，很有趣，我可以来去自如，所以是的，然后安迪加入了，这很有趣。是的，这是我那天晚上唯一期待的事情。你们做得很好。而且他，你知道，他偶尔喜欢喝一杯，所以他带我入了门。天哪，他很有趣，他是个有趣的家伙。
and it turned out I actually really liked it, it was fun, I could come and go, and so yeah, and then Andy joined, and it's been fun. Yeah, it's like the one thing I look forward to that evening. You guys are great at it. And he's, you know, he enjoys a little drink now and then, and so he broke me into that. God, he's fun, he's a fun dude.
现在，当你提到你妈妈发现你做这一切，想要去其他国家的疯狂局势中，像那样……如果你其中一个儿子跑过来说：“你知道吗，爸爸，我要去商店买点东西。”而他们身处波斯尼亚或其他什么地方，你会怎么做？嗯，你知道，我儿子才两岁……
Now, when you mentioned your mom finding out about, you know, you doing all this and wanting to go out in crazy situations in other countries, and be, you know, like that, are you do, what would you do if one of your sons came up and said, you know what, Dad, I'm gonna run out to the store really quick, and they're in Bosnia or whatever. Um, you know, well, you know, my son's two,
所以如果他那样做，我会非常担心。等他们长大了，等他们长大了。好吧。波斯尼亚现在其实很美。是的，好吧，抱歉。哦，一年中的这个时候，那里很好。是的。你知道，看，我希望我能成为那种……
so if he did that, I would be really concerned. When they're older, when they're older. Okay. Bosnia is actually gorgeous right now. Yeah, okay, sorry. Oh, it's this time of year, it's nice. Yeah. You know, look, I hope I would be the parent
支持孩子们想做的任何事情的父母，我会派一队前特种部队的人秘密跟着他。我肯定，我肯定。现在，在你走之前，我想听听你的播客。所以它叫《All There with Anderson Cooper》。现在，这是……
who's supportive of anything my kids want to do, and I would have a like a team of special force, former special forces, people secretly following him around. I'm sure, I'm sure. Now, before we let you go, I want to hear about your podcast. Now, so it's called All There with Anderson Cooper. Now, this is.
它叫《All There Is》，但没关系。不，那是《All There Is》。《All There Is》。《All There》，嗯，改得好，改得好。所以从那开始，不。这是关于你新闻工作之前的生活吗，是的？是的，特别是，这是一个播客……
It's called All There Is, but that's fine. No, that's all there is. All There Is. All There, well, good change, good change there. So started with all that, no. Is it, this has to do with a bit of your life before journalism, yes? Yeah, especially, it's a podcast,
就像世界需要另一个播客一样，但它只是一个有限的播客，八或十集左右，它是关于失去和悲伤的，它是关于，是的，它是关于人们对此的经历，以及带着它生活并走出来，这是我们不太谈论的事情，我认为，这让人感到不舒服……
like The World Needs Another podcast, but it's just a limited podcast, eight or 10 episodes or something, and it's about loss and about grief, and it's about, yeah, it's about people's experiences with that and living with that and moving through it, and it's something we don't really talk about, I think, and makes people uncomfortable,
所以我不知道是否真的有人会听，但它只是关于那些有非凡经历的人，谈论他们自己生活中的失去和悲伤，从斯蒂芬·科尔伯特开始，我知道你们请过他，我喜欢你们和他那集，他10岁时父亲和双胞胎兄弟在空难中丧生……
so I don't know if anyone will actually listen to it, but it's just interesting people who have kind of remarkable experiences, talk with loss and grief in their own life, from Stephen Colbert, who I know you guys have had on, I loved your episode with him, his father and his twin brothers were killed in a plane crash when he was 10 years old,
莫莉·香农，她也有过不可思议的经历，还有很多非常有趣的人，一位姑息治疗医生，他在许多人生命结束时都在床边，所以它只是关于……它并不压抑，它只是在谈论失去和悲伤。这是生活的一部分，我们前段时间请了作家迈克尔·刘易斯……
Molly Shannon, who has had the incredible experiences as well, and just really interesting people, a palliative care doctor who's been at the bedside of many people as their life ended, and so it's just about, it's not depressing, it's just kind of talking about loss and grief. It's part of life, and we had Michael Lewis, the author, on a while ago,
他谈论失去的方式是我从未听过的，这真的很了不起，非常感人，我想你是对的，我认为谈论它很重要，我会听的，我很期待。是的，你可以引导我们了解任何主题，它肯定会是令人愉快的。
and he talked about loss in a way that I'd never heard anybody talk about, and it's really remarkable and very moving, and I think you're right, I think it is important to talk about it, and I'll listen to it, I'm looking forward to it. Yeah, you could walk us through any subject, and it would be palatable for sure.
听着，没有人比我失去得更多，好吗？我的意思是，让我们面对现实吧，好吗？你这个可怜的家伙。你确实有很多损失。现在，为了和孩子们玩得开心，你喜欢做什么？他们喜欢什么？所以我儿子怀亚特两岁三个月或四个月大……
Listen, nobody has more losses than me, okay? I mean, let's get real, all right? You poor guy. You have a lot of losses. Now, for fun with the kids, what do you love to do? What are they loving? So my son Wyatt is like two years in like three or four months,
我儿子塞巴斯蒂安六个月大，他们只是……我的意思是，我一直想成为一名父亲，我爱孩子，这是我做过的最伟大的事情，这是唯一的事情，我的意思是，我只是对他们太着迷了，我没有什么比……你知道，我一天中大部分时间都和他们在一起……
and my son Sebastian is six months old, and they are just, I mean, I always wanted to be a dad, I love kids, and it's the greatest thing I've ever done, it's the only thing, I mean, I just am so besotted with them, and I like nothing more than, you know, I spend most, a lot of the day with them,
我的意思是，我现在很多工作都是在家做的，我喜欢在他早上醒来时在那里，我喜欢进去叫醒他，然后出去，我们出去喝咖啡，就像，他的第一句话是，“我要一杯黑咖啡”，这对于一个两岁的孩子来说可能不是什么好事。我要一杯黑咖啡。
I mean, I do a lot of work now just from home, I love being there when he wakes up in the morning, I like going in and waking him up in the morning, and going out, we go out for coffee, and like, his first phrase was, I want a black, a coffee, which is probably not a great thing for a two-year-old. I want a black coffee.
所以你现在有两个孩子了，你能够比较他们两个，还有那种年龄差距，大多数吹牛的人会说他们喜欢第一年，现在我肯定你会说同样的话，但既然你有一个超过第一年的孩子，两岁半，不觉得很神奇吗？还没到两岁。
So you've got, now that you've got two kids, and you're able to compare the two of them, and also the sort of the age difference there, most fibbers will say that they love the first year, now I'm sure you're gonna say the same thing, but now that you've got one that's beyond the first year, two and a half, don't like, isn't it amazing? Not quite two.
不，两岁半和六个月，对吧？快两岁半了，快两岁半了。所以对我来说，就像我的狗学会了说话，你知道，因为第一年，他们只是小狗，到处拉屎和尖叫，你只是……没有交流，然后突然之间，他们学会了说……
No, two and a half in six months, right? Almost two and a half, almost two and a half. So to me, it was like my dog learned how to talk, you know, because the whole first year, that's all they are is that they're just a puppy, they're shitting everywhere and screaming, and you just, there's no communication, and then all of a sudden, they learn how to say,
“我喜欢这个公园，不喜欢那个公园”，或者“这个食物，不喜欢那个食物”，这就像，直接冲破天花板。我知道，今天早上，就像，我儿子，他过来，就像，我在去上班前上楼，他看见我，他跑向我，拥抱我，这（你知道，显然他以前做过）……
I like this park and not that park, or this food and not that food, and it's like, right through the ceiling. I know, and this morning, like, my son, he came, like, I came upstairs right before I left for work, and he saw me, he ran to me, and like, hugged me, and which, you know, obviously he's done before,
但他现在太……太真实了，就像，我知道，你知道，他已经完全定型了，我只需要不把他搞砸，我只需要不把我的疯狂控制欲传给他。你不会的。我挺你。我挺你。
but he's just so pret, he's so there now, like, he's, I know, you know, he's all baked in there, like, I just need to not fuck him up, I just need to not, like, pass on my insane controlling, you know. You won't. I got you. I got you.
但我完全同意你的观点，我一直觉得，就像那只现在会说话的狗，这是有史以来最好的事情，就像，哦，天哪，我没想到还能更好，我觉得我的头和心都要爆炸了。所以你做了什么，安德森，你做了什么，因为你刚才说了，我了解你，一切都必须井井有条……
But I totally agree with you, I've been like, the dog who's now talking, it's the best thing ever, it's like, oh my God, I couldn't, I didn't think it could get any better, I feel like my head and my heart are about to explode. So what did you do, Anderson, what did you do, because you just said it, and I know this about you, everything has to be in order,
也许有点控制欲，也许只是，一切都有它的位置，然后现在你有两个可爱、了不起的男孩，他们扔东西、撞倒东西、弄脏东西，就在墙上，无论是什么，这会对你产生什么影响？你知道，我喜欢保持他们的东西，最终在他们睡觉时稍微干净一点……
maybe a little bit just controlling, maybe just, like, everything has its place, and then now you have two little adorable, amazing boys who throw things, knock things over, dirty shit up, right on the wall, like, whatever it is, does that, what does that do to you? You know, I like to keep their stuff, ultimately a little clean when they go to bed,
我清理一点，但我不想，但我不想，就像，我不想传递任何那种东西，所以我说，你知道吗，他们有整整一层楼，我在下面那一层，我住在一个旧消防站里，你知道，那是他们的楼层，我没问题。
I clean out a little bit, but I don't, but I don't, like, I don't wanna pass on any of that stuff, so I'm like, you know what, they have an entire floor to themselves, I'm on the floor right beneath, I live in an old firehouse, and you know, it's their floor, and I'm fine with it.
等等，你住在一个旧消防站里？我以为你住在时代华纳中心，你只是有一根消防杆，我就是那样想象你住的地方的，你只是滑下去。但有消防杆吗？顺便说一句，那一直是我的梦想，真实故事。是的，我保留了消防杆，当然。
Wait, you live in an old firehouse, I thought that you lived in the Time Warner Center, that you just had a fire pole, that's how I imagine how you live, that you just went down. But is there a fire pole, that's always my dream, by the way, true story. Yeah, I kept the fire poles, of course.
真的吗？是的。哦，天哪，我想去你家。后面有一个马厩，因为引擎是马拉的。请让我去你家，我想滑下那个东西。太棒了。所以我得到的是……
Truly? Yeah. Oh my God, I wanna come over. There's a stable in the back for horses, because the engines were horsed over. Please let me come over, I wanna slide down that thing. Amazing. So what I'm getting is,
你孩子住的楼层和你不一样。他说了。是的，是的。人们有不同的卧室，你和斯科蒂有不同的卧室。那是真的，那是真的。我们睡在不同的卧室。安德森，你去忙你的吧……
your kid's living on a different floor than you. He said it. Yeah, yes. People have different bedrooms, you and Scotty have different bedrooms. That's true, that's true. We sleep in separate bedrooms. Anderson, you go do your thing,
我们爱你，制作我们喜欢看的那些东西。我真的很喜欢你们所做的事情，我不敢相信我能参加这个节目，而且……没关系，你可以说你也爱我们。是的，我可以这么说。好吧，谢谢你做这件事。你真的很忙。
and we love you, making that stuff we love to watch. I really love what you guys do, and I can't believe I've been able to be on this, and it's... It's okay, you can say you love us too. Yeah, I can say it. Well, thank you for doing this. You're real, real busy.
你本来可以很容易地说不，但谢谢你没有。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢，安德森。很高兴见到你。真是太荣幸了。好吧，谢谢你们。再见，伙计。
You could have easily said no, but thank you for not. Thank you. Thank you. Thanks, Anderson. It's great to meet you. It's such a pleasure. All right, thank you guys. Bye, pal.
再见，伙计们。我真的很喜欢那个家伙，伙计们。我不在乎谁知道，我会从屋顶上大喊出来。他各方面都很风趣。我真的很喜欢他。我喜欢他开始破功的时候，当他开始笑的时候，他真的很搞笑。
See you guys, bye. I really like that fellow, guys. I don't care who knows it, I'll scream it from the rooftops. He's entertaining all the way around. I'm real sweet on him. I like it when he starts to break, when he starts to laugh, he's really funny.
是的，他开始咯咯笑。如果你没预料到，他开始咯咯笑。是的，这真的很有趣。但很聪明，像记者一样，但也，我本来要问他，因为杰森在你的介绍中说这个人有多么私密。我当时想，哦，我想知道他作为嘉宾会怎么样。然后你透露是安德森。
Yeah, he starts to titter. If you don't expect this, he starts to titter. Yeah, it's really fun. But brilliant, like journalists, but also, I was gonna ask him because Jason in your intro, you said how private this person was. I was like, oh, I wonder how they're gonna be as a guest. And you revealed that it was Anderson.
我知道他在出柜前有多么私密。他，似乎有什么……我本来要对他这么说，我也会当面对他这么说，但有点没完全投入。然后在他出柜后，就像，哦，那个人在那儿。现在他主持除夕夜，现在他出柜了……
And I know how private he was before he came out. He, there seemed to be something, I was gonna say this to him and I'll say this to him to his face, but a little not fully there. And then after he came out, it was like, oh, there's the guy. Now he's hosting New Year's Eve, now he's out
他很骄傲，他很高兴，他有家人，他有很多要分享的。你现在在电视上报道时能看到这一点。我觉得这真的，真的很好。我想知道他是否觉得那种……我不知道是不是因为同性恋的事情，抱歉。好吧，但也许是因为他想成为一个受人尊敬的记者……
and he's proud and he's happy as his family, he's a lot to share. And you see it now when he reports on TV and stuff. I think it's really, really great. I wonder if he felt like the sort of that. I don't know if it was the gay thing or not, I'm sorry. Well, but maybe like, because he wanted to be a respected journalism guy
爱德华·R·默罗和沃尔特·克朗凯特。这家伙，这家伙，不知道他在说什么。他需要表现得一本正经。然后一旦他……是的。所以现在他就像，是的。所以也许那是其中的一部分。也许那是，是的。我觉得他需要……
and Edward R. Murrow and Walter Cronk. This guy, this guy, don't know what he's talking about. And he needs to be all buttoned up. And then once he, yeah. So now he's like, yeah. So maybe that was a part of it. Maybe that, yeah. I feel like he needed to.
但无论如何，超级，超级棒的家伙，所以，顺便说一句，很有趣，真的很搞笑。是的，我想，听着，正如我所说，我想花更多时间和他在一起。我不知道你们是否有他的号码。我有，我有他所有的联系方式。他没有号码。同性恋，所有的同性恋者都有彼此的联系方式。
But anyway, super, super guy, so, and by the way, funny, like really funny. Yeah, I'd like, listen, as I said, I'd like to spend more time with him. I don't know if you guys have a number on him. I do, I have all its contact info. He doesn't have a number. Over gay, all the gay people have each other.
是这样吗？我觉得你在开玩笑，但那是真的吗？哦，他假设了。那是黄页，同性恋黄页。太棒了。我有很多，我有一堆非常好的笑话。我会告诉你这个，这是我理解过的尊重。
Is that right? I feel like you're joking, but is that true? Oh, he's assumed that. It's the yellow pages, the gay yellow pages. Wonderful stuff. I had so many, I had a bunch of really good jokes. I would tell you this, this is the respect that I ever understood.
我很惊讶你对“Plumpy Nut”没什么可说的。我想，我有的，我有的。我知道那也真的让我印象深刻。伙计们，我爱你们。我们今天没做什么聪明的事，只是说，嗨。哦，我们是吗？
I'm surprised you didn't have anything for plumpy nut. I thought, I did, I did. I know that really stuck out to me too. Guys, I love you. We're not doing anything clever today, but saying, Hi. Oh, we are?
就那样？是的，因为……好吧，你可以挂断了。威尔和我打算想点值得我们听众听的东西。是的，我们有一个很棒的听众。我不是说这是针对听众的。是的，听众，你知道……
Just that? Yeah, because- Well, you can hang up. Will and I are gonna think about something that's worthy of our listener. Yeah, we had a great listener. I was not saying it was against the listeners. Yeah, the listener, you know,
如果有人只是为了那个而收听呢？没错。你知道，他们只是……如果我们能触及一个孩子。他们调到三倍速，直到他们，是的，直到他们到达结尾。所以我们要坐在这里。肖恩，但你知道吗？
what if somebody just tunes in for that? Right. You know, they're just like- If we could reach one kid. They put out, there's a three-time speed until they get, yeah, until they get to the end. So we're gonna sit here. Sean, but you know what?
肖恩，我告诉你，我不会生你的气，你知道为什么吗？因为我会让往事随风。太棒了。太棒了。聪明。聪明。SmartLess。
Sean, I tell you what though, I'm not gonna be mad at you, you know why? Because I'm gonna let bygones be bygones. Wonderful. Wonderful. Smart. Smart. Loss.
SmartLess是由本内特·巴巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿姆贾夫手工制作的100%有机和艺术品。Smart。Less。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjarf. Smart. Loss. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLess 是由 Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob Amjarf 100% 有机且手工制作的。Smart. Loss. 本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。